let's go to our next caller. Our next caller is from the
701 area code. Caller from 701 say hello introduce yourself, and then tell me what's on your mind today
Hey, David. Paul from Fargo North Dakota. Great! I was kind of thinking- okay, thanks - I was kind of thinking
about a neutral strategy, and I've been thinking about this for a while
And I kind of did a little research to see if I could find some hard facts or information about like a new strategy
why democrats keep losing trying to figure out a new strategy and I wonder if if you are
maybe the viewers are aware of a specific study, that's been done a very simple one just
calling Red States or Swing states and saying this one question
"what would make you vote for a democrat over a republican?" and then taking that data and
breaking the answers into categories and percentages and then kind of taking that and making a platform or
adjusting the current one as necessary. (David): okay very good so and I think about a couple aspects of that number one
The idea you're already thinking in the right
line of thought by saying that democrats need to come up with some kind of cohesive strategy and between you know corporate
Democrats and
Progressive Democrats and establishment there needs to be some kind of uniting platform that goes beyond
We aren't Trump and we aren't the republicans
so that's really really good number two where you're on the right track is in trying to figure out well, okay a
Progressive
Center-Left Moderates Democrats, etc. They're overwhelmingly going to vote for the democratic candidates
So what can be done to expand the pie of people that might vote for a democrat or the more progressive
candidate in an election?
And why not go to the issues and try to figure that out? the only place where I would be careful is
We're usually
Incredibly critical of
politicians who come up with
basically poll tested positions because it ends up feeling inauthentic.
And while you could certainly start calling around, Pat, and saying hey
What would make you in Missouri as a republican vote for a democrat? and would make you in Arizona vote for a democrat? and whatever
You'd get useful information, but crafting a platform around that I would worry would be part of the same corporate approach to
Democrats inc as I call it. Well. I do like this Peter bogosian-esc
epistemology type approach. The problem is I think you're really trying to appeal to the
Independents in the Middle who can be swayed one way or another and maybe they are not voting on policy.
Maybe it's just if they if they like the candidate personally or not
You know Barack Obama is an entertaining guy Donald Trump's an entertaining guy I could see a lot of people
Having voted for both of them
And you know maybe they'll have to choose the sexiest can at the next time around again. (David): the other problem Paul with what you're suggesting
And again you're thinking of the right things. It's just what I'm seeing is maybe the possible holes in it is many times
voters vote against their own best interests particularly republican voters so you might get a voter who says oh
I would vote for a democrat if I believed that they were going to lead me to a better health care situation and
Then they actually end up voting for the republican anyway because they either don't understand the positions of the two, or
fall
victims to propaganda or whatever so the questions you're asking or proposing asking are great questions
But we have to make sure that it's actionable in a way that will work, and I worry that it's not
right
Yeah, I guess I've always just kind of wondered - you know
And I like I like what a lot of what you said
Just you know if there are some people say you know who are in that situation where they want better health care
But then they say well, you know, but I can't vote for the Democrat because well
They're okay with you know a woman being able to
Have an abortion you know Etc
So so I'm gonna not vote for that. You know I wonder it's like the social issues
Or that can hold back everything else (David): yeah, that's another good point. That's another good point great question paul really appreciate it
I think you're thinking about exactly the right issues that democrats need to be thinking about going towards the
2018 and 2020 election no doubt about it. All right very much appreciate the call